having previously discussed how many of
the deities that appear in Shinto and
Japanese mythology were created by their
Izanami and Izanagi it is another one of
their many children that will be taking
a look at today reijin they got a
thunder and lightning now as his name
would suggest much of the bad weather in
Japan is often attributed to reijin as
it's believed he controlled thunder and
lightning with his brother Fujin
controlling the wind he's named the rice
in the Japanese word R I mean in thunder
and shin meaning car me or God so if you
don't happen to be Japanese and like me
you've always wondered whether Pokemon
right you got its name from weave
rhyming in Thunder and true meaning kiss
or referring to the sound of a kiss that
would make its name thunder kiss in
Japanese and there we have today's
useless and completely unrelated fact of
the day now back to the actual video in
Japan ryan did go by several other names
including ride and summer meaning
thunder and lightning master kaminari
summer mean thunder master an alchemy
roughly translated to mean a deity of
role in thunder the appearance of reijin
is one that many will be familiar with
as statues of him can be found all over
Japan he often appears as a [ __ ]
demonic spirit beat in his drums from
which he creates thunder and lightning
some aspects of his physical depictions
do seem to change sometimes he appears
very muscular and other times he appears
as having a potbelly but what doesn't
seem to change is he's menacing and
slightly terrifying persona which is not
too different from the unpredictable and
frightening nature of thunder and
lightning the drums of Rajan almost
always seem to have a symbol drawn onto
them the tamo symbol which was quite
common in shinto culture and was thought
to add many meanings relate him back to
nature in some parts of japan he was
referred to as Ryden and he would often
appear as a robes man in a straw hat a
very clear influence for the mortal
kombat character of the same name now as
we mentioned earlier reijin was one of
the many offspring of the Izanagi and
there's an army but some believe that he
wasn't born into off there is an Army's
death when she was sent to the
underworld
he was also amongst the eight spirits
that pursued his father when he
attempted to flee riten and his brother
Fujin were fairly respected deities but
with japan been an island nation known
for having a fair amount of storms and
typhoons
they were also extremely feared
a story that I came across that attempts
to explain some of the respect that the
Japanese people felt towards her brother
deities takes place in the years 1274
and 1281 when Kublai Khan and the Mongol
Empire attempted to invade Japan they
were pushed back by typhoons and
treacherous weather conditions after two
unsuccessful attempts to conquer Japan
the mortal chose to cease their plans in
ever invade in Japan again these storms
were said to have manifested out of
nowhere and many saw them as miracles
created by ryan and his brother who
intervened to protect in japan in its
time of need this may also be one of the
reasons that we see statues of Ryan and
Fujian outside the holy places and
temples of Japan acting as sworn
protectors another with an intriguing
story that I came across portrays Ryan
as a demon but also a force of nature
there is an old wives tale told to
children by their mothers warning them
to cover their belly buttons during
storms or Ryan would kidnap them and
devour their bellies there are some
similar tales that believe it was not
Ryan who devoured the neighbors of
children but instead ride you a white
and blue wolf covered in lightning that
accompanies a Japanese got a thunder
the wolf is said to normally be quite
calm but during thunderstorms it's said
to become very agitated and
uncomfortable and it finds comfort in
sleeping inside a person's navel it was
then believed that Ryan would help bolts
of lightning at the navel of the person
that the wolf resides him creating the
superstition of sleeping on your belly
during the winter I hope you've enjoyed
taking another look at one of the many
iconic deities that features in Japanese
and Shinto mythology if you have any
stories or thoughts on writing that
you'd like to share with me then please
do so in the comments below
as always I've been your host mythology
and fiction explain
you